[Música]
hola hola marc me gusta un privilegio
estar acá con ustedes como decía pablo
efectivamente el ilusionismo psicológico
es como en lugar de sacar conejos del
sombrero lo que sacamos son pensamientos
de las mentes del público les gustaría
probar
no los escucho
me parece genial porque tengo acá una
tarjeta de crédito con mil dólares y
quiero lanzarla al público a los que
estén más animados
son mil dólares de este lado
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ganaron por el momento estos quien le
agarre
bien tire todo el piso de importa más
importante la planta tiene las bases
quien la tiene
que se ponga de pie por favor
a nada más quería la plata bueno primero
que todo quiero aclarar que la tarjeta
es mía yo te dije que le iba a regalar
nada más dice que tenía ganas de
lanzarla bien lo segundo es preguntarle
o se tiene una cuenta en el banco
supongo como la mayoría gente y tiene un
pin para acceder al cajero de 4 dígitos
y lo recuerdan y no sólo contaban a de
alrededor y no estamos de acuerdo porque
la tarjeta pudo caer en cualquier la
cierta venga por favor por acá démosle
un fuerte aplauso ella
mientras ella se acerca
antes antes antes de que suba les voy a
contar algo curioso de todos los retos
que he tenido en mi carrera artística el
reto para mí más interesante más
emocionante ha sido el tratar de lograr
modernizar el arte del ilusionismo
psicológico o de lo que llamamos
mentalismo sin que se vuelva a moderno
que se vuelva actual que sea algo que la
gente pueda entender por ejemplo
anteriormente algo como adivinar el
horóscopo el signo zodiacal de alguien
era sumamente sorprendente si nos vamos
mucho tiempo atrás no sé babilonia y
usted de repente hacía eso yo llego
traigo a alguien y le adivinó su signo
zodiacal bueno se asusta montones y no
sabe ni qué pensar por qué porque es
algo íntimo que tiene que ver con la
persona no solamente con ella sino con
su familia con lo que ha vivido incluso
con lo que va a vivir pero actualmente
si hago eso ustedes se sorprenderían tal
vez algunos si yo no yo soy muy
incrédulo soy escéptico no creo en esto
del horóscopo pero
tal vez y se hace distinto en lugar de
adivinar algo como eso se deben a algo
más privado y peligroso como la clave
del banco
suya
venga por favor por acá va más fuerte el
aplauso de ella
no me de la tarjeta todavía con lo que
se queda cuál es su nombre
silvana silvana silvana quiero que se
imaginen a partir de ahora de que yo soy
un cajero
y listo ok bm no deje verme a mi mano
vea mi mano
ahora ve a la tarjeta y piense que hay
atrás en la parte de atrás si en el
papelito que ahí está escrito su número
de pin no lo digan cuatro dígitos cierto
no lo diga
ahora lentamente se va a acercar al
cajero o sea yo todavía no es tranquila
relax
lentamente viéndome a los ojos pensando
que yo soy un cajero adelante
e introduce la tarjeta
no me la da en la mano
ok voy a hacer para esto un lápiz y le
voy a pedir por favor que coloque su
mano derecha sobre mi hombro sin miedo
es importante un poquito con peso
silvana cierto bien si hermana quiero
que piense ahora en el primer dígito de
su cuenta no lo digas perdón de la
cuenta no del pin
e imaginé que lo está escribiendo en mi
espalda pero no lo haga nada más piense
que su mano se va a levantar y tocar ese
primer botón lo está pensando ahora no
lo diga
2 ustedes pueden ver la reacción ya no 3
4 5 6
ok
tengo algo acá pensando el segundo
dígito o el más rápido lo tienes pensar
que lo estás tocando ahora
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
ok voy a arriesgar
pensar en el tercer dígito
0 1 2 3 4 5 54 32 10
8 905
ok
en el último dígito ya con eso ya puedo
saquear sus cuentas
sólo piense en él no voy a decir nada
porque no vamos a jugar con él estás
pensando en él
perfecto tome la piscina nueva ocupar
más
puede girar regresa si quiere al
micrófono
silvana puede que me haya equivocado en
uno o dos espero que me perdonen
personas del mundo cuál es su primer
dígito el que primero que pensó al
micrófono cual cero
genial segundo es el que creo que falle
6 hay algo especial con ese es no no me
diga
en el cumpleaños cierto escuché bien el
tercero cuáles 00 también ok hay algo
importante con respecto al cuarto que
quiero que veas aquí el cuarto el que no
no dijiste ningún momento el cuarto lo
que hice fue poner que una equis porque
es muy secreto y no quiero silvana que
te enteres pero si estamos bien es 060 y
el secreto quiere leer esto en voz alta
0 60 x fuerte la pausa ella que lo hizo
genial muy bien
[Aplausos]
antes de que se vaya importante con
respecto al último dígito un secreto
segura bueno ya sabe vaya cambia la
clave entonces para que nadie sepa
fuerte el aplauso en ella puede tomar
asientos gracias
ok
le gusta
quieren más pues me parece genial porque
tengo acá un sobre con dinero en
efectivo para el público más animada
[Aplausos]
ha llamado por aquello ha afirmado sí
con fecha por otro lado para que no me
lo quieran cambiar antes de llegar acá
al escenario me ha pasado me ha pasado
es que usted o bien puede ser que no
lleguemos lejos está un poco robado y
ahí va listo señor hasta que esto ha
sido tranquilo y relajado y le va bien
justo si usted está hablando y no lo
logra agarrar bien
no tiene alguien caballero su nombre ok
no lo escuchan importante importante
importante venga por aquí sí venga de
este lado y mientras él sube mientras él
llega acá
que por cierto a la muchacha que casi le
cae en el ojo porque estaba con el
celular verdad no no y lo digo porque es
importante resulta que durante mucho
tiempo
y me molestaba eso de que uno llega a un
evento y todo el mundo está con el
celular muy bien a veces tomando fotos
una historia o algo y me peleaba con esa
realidad conmigo mismo oa veces con el
público nos agarramos a golpes
si hay vídeos lo cierto es que luego me
di cuenta que el que estaba mal era yo
que no me me percataba que esa
incomodidad que sentía cuando el público
tomaba esa actitud era era yo el que
tenía que cambiar que tenía que innovar
que tenía que acoplarme a lo que venía
por eso quiero que todos saquen el
celular ahora vamos a sacar el celular
sáquenlo
no tiene batería lo siento salga de la
sala se fue a quedar un rato se puede
quedar en el celular y de nosotros
desaparece es más ahora instagram ahora
ahora lo no pasa nada nadie les va a
decir nada no están en la u
y quien no tiene por favor 2019 además
observan deben buscar
no piense mal nada más deben buscar
alejandro nava ser es parte del acto
alejandro navas se reponga en eso entre
no tiene que seguir me no me sigan bueno
si quieren no no lo hagan como quieran
en la vida ustedes cuando lo tengan a y
apaguen el teléfono y guárdelo un
momento
si alejandro navas er y démosle un
fuerte aplauso
a nuestro ganador
vamos fuerte la plaza
cuál es su nombre
verdad
el micrófono de clic clic clic quiero
que tomen sobre con dinero y lo guardan
en sus bolsillos y quieren el bolsillo
de atrás para que sea mejor si estoy
bien
excelente clay te cuento tengo por acá
un mazo de cartas
pero a diferencia de lo común que se
hace con un mazo de cartas y que la
gente lo puede mezclar y demás no sé si
medio lo pueden apreciar acá este mazo
de cartas está engarzado klein acercaos
para que puedas ver está engarzado las
cartas dentro de un candado cierto
revise que así de si están dentro si
usted las abre así usted las puede ver
que son todas las cartas distintas poder
verlas abril
repasando cartas cartas engarzadas por
un candado porque porque los magos de
repente sacan cosas y manipulan y yo no
quiero manipular cartas quiero manipular
su mente que estaba de acuerdo entonces
lee
para que esto sea todavía más extraño te
voy a poner esto acá en el bolsillo y
colgando y puedo pedir que por favor
mezcles así un poco mezcla un poco
con esta velocidad característica de ley
excelente
muy bien ahora bien dónde está quiero
que haga así abre un poquito como el
lado suyo para que yo no vea ahí doblas
y y veo una carta la memoria está ahora
y se asoma así bien viste una cual viste
es decir
tres de tres exacto puedes ver
cualquiera es cierto porque él
simplemente abre de esta forma por
cualquier carta en cualquier posición si
esta vez vas a hacerlo igual pero vas a
alcanzar luego las cartas entonces
habría así de esta forma abrir primero
ahora días o meses lea la carta memorice
la pongan el candado estamos de acuerdo
público que vamos a estas circunstancias
lo único que yo puedo manipular en la
mente de glen klein
déjame los ojos
no deje de verme
déjame a los ojos
no deje de ver
klein
me dijo 32 me dijo otra carta me dijo
cuál
8 / 18 de 31 eso fue lo que me dijo es
cierto porque es a la carta que él vio
estamos de acuerdo
genial
ahora viene lo extraño esto que es
totalmente libre él pudo cortar a unir
hacer lo que él quiso ser imposible bajo
estas circunstancias creen que todo esto
ya estuviera escrito tiene la llave
escrito nos trabamos lo hubiera puesto
en un sobre algo por el estilo pero no
en su instagram en el mío sí claro
entren a las historias entren a las
historias y ayuden a encontrar algo muy
peculiar y no tiene teléfono no tiene
batería lo podemos ver justo acá
cansado a perder las cargas les puse un
candado
el problema es que no puedo sacar las
cartas a menos de que la rompa
ahí sacuda cartílago o al azar puede ser
cualquier carta cual carta puede ser
cualquiera
klein
8 el trébol
el 8 de tres gracias
cuando yo esperaba un grito más fuerte
pero no importa yo sé que pasa falta
algo paso problema que si yo ran que la
carta glenn si yo arranqué la carta
quiere decir que usted jamás la pudo
haber visto
pase las cartas no del frente sí y
busque su carta
no que no está el 8 de trébol
como no está fácil nuevo revise usted
creo en lo visto está seguro
la siguiente historia
carta puntos tiras teléfono al aire y
grita
[Música]
el sobre
ahora lo por favor
es un obsequio para usted gracias a que
el fuerte la plaza cree
recuerde si de repente se sienten
incómodos dentro de 20 años estamos
jóvenes 20-30 años por los avances
tecnológicos se molestan de algo no se
molesten que se cuenta que ese es el
momento justo donde hay que innovar así
que no lo olvides gracias muchísimas
gracias y que disfruten
[Aplausos]
[Música]